Hi.
So today,
human emotion,
we're going to talk about the way in which emotion shaped the way that we think.
And here we'll be trying to answer some of the biggest questions that have
plagued the field of emotion for decades.
That is in what way is emotion really distinct from thinking?
So we used to think of emotion and cognition as to vastly separate entities that
were even at odds with each other.
We know now through recruiting scientific evidence that in fact they're not only
not at odds,
but in fact,
as you can see here,
they overlap an important and an interesting ways.
And in particular we've talked earlier in this series and emotion and cognition
and the ways in which feelings actually do shape the way we think.
However,
most of what we've talked about so far has been talking about relatively
conscious types of thoughts,
memories,
and perceptions.
Yet to what extent can emotions actually shaped the way we think,
even unconsciously,
sort of outside of our awareness completely.
So in other words,
can emotions actually be unconscious?
So this is this idea of is really all we're is.
Most of what we're seeing really below the surface and in fact unconscious and
that most of our conscious life is really just a mere tip of the iceberg.
So today we're going to try to delve deep into this idea of unconscious
emotional experiences.
And by doing so we're going to really try to probe into this idea of the
psychological unconscious.
So by the psychological unconscious,
as you can see here,
what we're referring to is the conscious experience,
thought and action that's influenced by percepts memories and other mental
states which are inaccessible to phenomenal awareness and somehow independent of
voluntary control.
So indeed many of our mental states,
and perhaps even our emotions may not be fully accessible to us and we actually
may not be fully aware of all the powerful influence our feelings are having on
our everyday life.
And the way we think about the world,
the way we judge other people,
and the way we decide what we like and what we don't like.
So today this is going to be our third segment on emotion and cognition.
And we're going to be delving deep into the unconscious.
And looking at the question of can feelings actually be unconscious?
And if they can,
what role do they play in our lives?
Do they shape who we are,
what we do,
how we perceive the world in ways that we may not at all be aware of?
So our roadmap today is going to go as follows.
We're going to start with some origins,
sort of where did this idea that emotions can even be unconscious first begin.
Then we're going to turn to some recent empirical studies that focus on priming
studies,
which we'll talk about in a moment as one really innovative paradigm to get at
unconscious emotional processes.
Then we'll conclude with our takeaway questions and expert interview for this
particular module.
So let's start with origins.
In other words,
where did this idea that emotions can be unconscious even begin?
So here we're going to delve into the unconscious emotional life that really
originated with Sigmund Freud and Carl Young.
So Sigmund Freud said,
our right to assume the existence of something mental that is unconscious and to
deploy that assumption for the purposes of scientific terrific work is disputed
in many quarters.
To this,
we can reply that our assumption of the ICAN conscious is necessary and
legitimate and that we possess numerous proofs of its existence.
So again,
he argued that of course we have a rich unconscious life and that there's many,
many instances that proves its existence.
And so for those of you who have taken maybe introductory to psychology,
this might look familiar to you.
So here is Freud and his sort of depiction of our mental life.
So he sort of thought about it in many different stages of things being
unconscious,
preconscious and even conscious,
right?
And the important part here is that he assumed that much of our mental life was
largely unconscious.
So below this sort of level of awareness or below the ocean of awareness,
if you think of that metaphor of an iceberg,
right?
And he further reason that much of our mental suffering and distress arose from
conflict among different unconscious forces.
So he would talk about the ID,
right as the sort of sole seat of unconscious desires and passions and
aggressions.
Whereas the Super Ego was really sort of our external societal norms.
And here we are for most of our lives,
sitting at the ego,
which is really trying to reconcile the desires of the ID and the social norms
of the Super Ego.
So what's important here is that he did pause it.
A large portion of our life is largely unconscious.
And that in fact,
much of our unconscious experience manifested through our dreams and our
impulses actually has important rich symbolic meaning as well.
So he was really one of the first people to really spend a lot of time
emphasizing the role of the unconscious and a lot of our emotional states that
arise from it.
But he focused primarily on aggression and sexual impulses.
Another famous figure in this field was Carl Young,
who also really emphasize the role of the unconscious.
And he said,
until you make the unconscious conscious,
it will direct your life and you will call it fate.
And so he also said in addition to our immediate consciousness,
which is of a thoroughly personal nature and which we believe to be the only
empirical psyche,
even if we tack on the personal unconscious as an appendix,
he said there exists a second psychic system of a collective universal and in
personal nature,
which is identical in all individuals.
This collective unconscious does not develop individually,
but in fact is inherited.
It consists of preexistent forms,
what he called the archetypes,
which can only become conscious secondarily,
and which give definite form to certain psychic events.
So it's important to take home here as Carl Young also emphasize the role of the
unconscious.
But he said,
not only do we have our own personal or individual unconscious mental life,
but that as a human species,
we also partake in what's called the more collective unconscious,
shared among in many individuals and with important symbolic forms are
archetypes.
So again,
what I want you to take home here is that we have two early predecessors for it
and young who have really put forth this idea that the unconscious plays a vital
role in our psychological life.
And emotional wellbeing.
Um,
since then there had been some early studies on Korsakoff Syndrome that further
really emphasize the role of the unconscious.
So here what you see,
so this is a study that was done.
You can see here in the early 19 hundreds,
um,
in a classic demonstration of what we have now come to call spared implicit
memory or an organic amnesia.
The researcher who did this study,
um,
on Korsakoff Syndrome,
uh,
pricked and unsuspecting Korsakoff Syndrome patient with a pin hidden in his
hand and event that had caused the patient quite a bit of distress of course.
And when the researcher subsequently left the room and returned after the
patient had regained her composure and failed to even recognize who the
researcher was,
had no recollection of this unfortunate incident that had just transpired
between them.
However,
nonetheless,
the patient with Korsakoff Syndrome that has a form of organic amnesia refused
to shake the researchers hand.
When asked why she replied,
well,
sometimes people hide pins in their hands.
And so this story illustrates this phenomena of what they call source amnesia.
Familiar in many studies of memory.
And what's most important here is that assumes that the patient shaking hands,
um,
it made the patient nervous as well.
Although the patient didn't know why.
So they had an emotional reaction without any conscious awareness as to what
might have caused that feeling or that reticence of shaking the experimenters
hands.
So this was an early study that suggests there may be a dissociation between
conscious awareness of an emotional state and sort of understanding its
influence on subsequent behavior.
So these are some early origins.
And now I want to turn to more recent experimental studies in the realm of
priming that have really given a new vitality and force this idea of the
unconscious emotional life.
So I want to start here with some studies that were done by Robert Science on
what he called the mere exposure effect.
So this is really interesting work.
So what happened in these studies,
the near exposure affect what essentially posits that repeated exposure to some
given stimulus increases liking.
So the more familiar you are with some given symbol,
the more you like it.
And he used an example in his study of Chinese ideograms.
So in the 1960s,
Robert Science conducted a series of experiments which demonstrated that simply
exposing participants too unfamiliar stimulates such as Chinese ideograms.
So individuals who weren't fluent in China,
Chinese themselves actually led them to rate these images more positively than
other similar stimuli that they had not been previously exposed to.
So in other words,
by simply seeing an image,
you're more likely to have positive emotional feelings to it,
even if you can't consciously recall having seen that image before.
Right?
Um,
or even if they presented these images that very,
very quick brief durations that couldn't be consciously recalled or or
remembered.
So when these another words you and presenting these subliminally very quickly,
you know,
in a way that can't be consciously recalled,
it still produced the same effect of liking these Chinese symbols more than
unfamiliar symbols that people hadn't previously seen.
So this led Zions to conclude this famous quote here that mere preferences need
no inferences.
So we may simply like things without having any conscious inference or reason as
to why.
Then there were a series of emotional priming studies.
So here emotional faces were presented subliminally.
So that's at a rapid speed that cannot be consciously perceived and found that
even in these instances,
we're finding that when you present people really rapidly with stimulate,
it influences how they feel,
even though they can't consciously tell you why or can't consciously recall even
having seen that image.
So one example of this sort of subliminal face priming is a study where
individuals were primed with negative pictures of faces.
So like,
uh,
a frowny face here,
right?
And they were flashed for a quick instant.
And what happened here is that graduate students tended to rate their own
research more negatively when they were primed with a really brief image of a
negative face,
right?
Um,
and they would even evaluate more neutral stimuli in a more negative light.
So another words,
what this scowling face presented really briefly,
really instantly and which graduate students couldn't even recall having seen it
actually shaped the way they not only evaluated neutral stimuli,
but even how they evaluated their own very personal research ideas.
So in a way,
this can even shape the way that you emotionally feel about yourself.
Not just,
you know,
Chinese idiom grams are not just sort of external neutral stimuli,
but that there's this really powerful force of presenting emotional stimuli
rapidly that shapes a wide range of,
of stimuli and how you emotionally feel about them.
Then there's been a series of studies that have really been pushed forward by a
of mine here at yelling university doctor John Barge,
who's looked further at what else emotion priming can do.
So can we actually experienced physical warmth in a way that unconsciously
promotes a social warmth or emotional feelings of affiliate iveness towards
others.
So in a study done by Lawrence wines and John Barge that was published,
published in science,
they argued this,
this claim that experience visit physical warmth actually promotes interpersonal
warmth.
So you can see here in the abstract,
they argue that warmth is one of the most powerful personality traits and social
judgment,
right?
And what they found here,
it's very fascinating that they hypothesize that experiences of physical warmth
or coolness would increase feelings of social warrant,
their coldness without a person even being aware of their influence.
So they did this in a really clever way.
So they had participants briefly hold a cup of either hot or iced coffee.
And then they were later asked to judge an unfamiliar target person,
um,
as having either a more warm personality or more cold personality.
And they found indeed that individuals who've held that Warm Cup of coffee later
rated an unfamiliar strangers having a warmer personality,
being more generous and more caring,
and that they were even more likely to choose a gift for a friend instead of
themselves.
So what I want to show you here is a brief five minute video of Dr John Barge,
sharing some of these provocative and really groundbreaking studies showing just
how powerful nonconscious emotional priming can be,
even by simply holding a cup of warm or hot coffee or warm or cold coffee.
That is
[inaudible]
1996 professor John bodge shocked to Doug rage,
his fellow psychologists by publishing studies,
which controversially showed that our decisions can be subliminally manipulated,
had fruit thrown at me at these talks when I give these results early in the
90s.
And they were joking,
you know,
but I had apples and oranges lobbed at me because they thought you're going too
far.
I have ceased being surprised at the results of these studies.
Uh,
the only because of all the long experience with these things keep working
subliminal effect that rattled so many cages is called prime.
You're watching television or watching a movie or reading a book and what's
happening in the movie or TV.
It could be something or someone doing something very brave.
And that just by itself activates ideas and the concept of bravery.
And you might be more likely to see another person as a brave person or another
person as a kind person or an intelligent person,
more than usual and more than you have had the prior,
prior event not happened.
And that's the nature of priming
images and even words slipping thoughts and feelings into our subconscious is
one thing.
But what is more worrying is how those thoughts and feelings can then change our
behavior.
Today,
one of John Barges,
Phd Students,
is running an experiment to investigate the priming effects of temperature.
What we do in our experiment,
we very briefly,
I suppose people to a warm or cold substance and what we expect to happen is
that that simple experience with a warm substance or a cold subs as well,
prime people to sort of activate these uh,
feelings of warmth and comfort and the things that we've learned about since we
were very young.
Yes,
and when we have those things in mind,
those things we know will color people's judgements and decisions and their
behaviors as well.
Volunteers for the experiment or asked to hold a warm cup of coffee as they are
met by Lawrence.
They had been primed with heat.
The purpose of the experiment is to record participants judgments about
Lawrence's colleague Randy.
That was great.
It was awesome.
Until I got stranded in Florida,
there's a snowstorm.
The theory is that the hot drink will somehow elicit positive feelings towards
Randy even several minutes after experiencing the warmth of the cup and he has
the killer question.
Would you give Randy permanent job
based on your belief and scratching or for India which you hired?
Her last project manager seemed like a generally friendly guy,
so yeah,
I would say so.
Yeah.
We're not
sure.
Yes.
Saying warm and friendly things about a stranger might just be the normal polite
response time to cool things down
except for the
temperature of the drink.
Identical conditions.
The same conversation with Randy,
not risky and six minutes later the same questions from Lawrence.
Based on your a brief interaction with coaching,
you recommend him or would you hire Randy as project manager
as a leader?
I'm not sure.
Based on the brief interaction,
no,
maybe not from the impression that I got.
The experiment
shows remarkably that a brief encounter with a beverage could see you either
hired or fired.
It's a powerful effect and one that might have worrying applications
and the case of say a consumer products I'm feeling warm about a product
presumably will make you more likely to buy it.
I'm feeling warm about a spokesperson may make you be more likely to listen to
that person and trust their judgment.
So the web politicians handing your cups of coffee,
right?
Essentially.
Essentially,
yes.
People say,
how can you get these effects with such a rinky dink little manipulations and
moving people's behavior all over the place.
And we also,
where you get a little defensive when we hear that,
and I don't know,
it just keeps working.
We do these things and they work and that's,
you know,
sorry.
But they do.
And now our job is to understand and try to explain to people why that is.
Why does the human mind is constructed in a way that you can get these effects
at all?
So I'm going to walk you through just a couple of other examples of these
powerful studies that have done primarily by doctor John Barge.
This one looking at the way in which we can unconsciously regulate our emotions.
So this study is called keeping one's distance,
the influence of spacial distance cues on an effect and evaluation.
So in this study,
participants were randomly assigned to simply plot points on a Cartesian grid
here,
either points that were close together,
intermediate,
or far apart.
And in other words,
within the frame of this Cartesian plane,
the points used in this study were manipulating people's physical sense of
either being physically close or physically far away.
After simply pop plotting points on a graph,
participants were asked to read a book passage and answer some questions that
assess the extent to which they enjoyed or liked the excerpt.
And what they found in the study quite powerfully is that simply manipulating
physical distance,
radically shift people's self reported enjoyment levels.
So those who plotted two points that were closer together.
Um,
if you see here,
um,
that they actually,
it influenced the degree to which they reported self reported enjoyment here.
So the mere activation of physical distance concepts of near versus far without
any explicit reference to the self or social concepts is sufficient to influence
people's evaluations and emotions in terms of how much they actually enjoy
something powerfully enough.
Um,
so in other words,
people primed with a spacial distance condition on the right,
enjoyed the excerpt more than those prime to spacial closeness and the
intermediate condition.
Lastly,
but not least,
I'm a recent study,
looked at this,
um,
by looking at what they called the substitute substitutability of physical and
social warmth in everyday life.
So here what they did is they had people fill out questionnaire measures of self
self-reported loneliness.
Afterwards they filled out questionnaires that ask them the frequency in which
they took either warm or cold showers or baths.
And what they found here,
if you look at the relationship between loneliness and the tendency to take warm
showers,
is that they found that those people who are higher in self reported loneliness
were actually associated with an increased tendency to take warm showers or
baths.
So in a sense,
it seems that people who are feeling lonely,
sort of emotionally cold may unconsciously try to regulate this sense of
emotional coldness through physical warmth,
by taking a warmer shower or warmer bath.
And they've also replicated this in coldness manipulations that make people feel
lonelier as well.
So in some ways mean we may be trying to unconsciously regulate our emotions in
ways that we have no idea were even doing in our everyday life.
Um,
and this has gained a lot,
this particular study gained a lot of widespread media attention.
So feeling lonely,
take a warm bath.
Um,
in other words,
this idea of really looking at unconscious forces on our emotions,
our social preferences,
how we regulate our emotions.
It's something that seems to capture a lot of excitement and a lot of attention
from the general public as well.
So now I want to conclude with our takeaway questions.
We've talked about the origins of unconscious emotions,
recent priming studies.
So what are some of the important points to take away from today?
First,
what did early theorists such as Freud and young posit about the role of the
unconscious in emotional life?
Second,
what did early studies on subliminal priming reveal about the nature of
unconscious emotion?
And finally,
can you describe several experimental studies that we recently discussed towards
the end of lecture today about priming on emotion,
emotion regulation,
and social perceptions of others.
And now we'll turn to our expert interview as part of the experts and emotion
interview series.
Today we'll be speaking with doctor John Barge from Yale University on
unconscious emotion.
Dr Barge received his phd at the University of Michigan and is currently a
professor at Yale University where he directs the automaticity and cognition,
motivation and evaluation or acne laboratory.
Dr Barges work focuses on automaticity and unconscious processing as a method to
better understand social behavior as well as philosophical topics such as
freewill.
Much of doctor barges work investigates whether behavior is thought to be under
volitional control,
may actually result from more automatic interpretations of,
as well as reactions to external stimuli such as words.
He's received numerous awards for his achievements as well as discussion and top
tier media outlets.
So I now turn to a very special experts and emotion interview with my colleague,
Doctor Barge.